the emotional side is where we start to
understand
our feelings and we let ourselves feel
our feelings so they come out
so the practice with emotional
well-being is journaling i think is the
easiest thing
i journal just a couple minutes a day
it's a safe space to be authentic and to
see
your feelings and to see and you can
start to sit back and separate from your
feelings
um so i teach a lot about journaling
because i think even with your best
friends or your mom or your husband or
your wife
you don't want to share everything right
but we know that
emotional well-being and mental health
is related to bloating it is related to
inflammation it is related to aging so
even though you don't see it
if you just sit there all day and anger
and things become unresolved it really
starts to break down your body
i believe that each and every one of us
has the power within ourselves
to create the life that we really want
and i want to help give you the tools to
make that happen
i'm danica patrick and i'm pretty
intense
today we have the beautiful kimberly
snyder
kimberly's been involved in health and
wellness for a long time
and she has helped so many celebrities
um
with their food with their diet
foundationally
she has what's called the four
cornerstones and that would be food
body emotional well-being and spiritual
growth
and so she describes that they all need
to be in balance otherwise we put too
much focus on
on the other three or two or one
whatever it may be
and so it's about sort of cultivating a
practice for each one of those
and and um and then really getting into
our body and less about the external and
more about the internal
we talked about her past and what led
her to being interested in wellness
um and then where she is now uh so she
has a podcast called the feel good
podcast
and she also has a product line called
seluna
basically by the end of this you're
going to be ordering selena products
and you're probably going to be tuning
into her podcast to get more information
because
she is a wealth of it so enjoy the show
today
oh it's so nice to meet you in person i
do if you remember this but we had i had
my first juice shop i think you did a
couple cleanses there
i totally did and i was just telling my
producer jen about this i was like
man back in the day i ordered glow bio
is it yes and um i was trying
i was looking to do it again like maybe
i don't know i feel like it was like a
year ago and i'm like dude
go on i'm like wait like
wait hang on this doesn't exist anymore
is that true we moved into the four
seasons actually so my lifestyle brand
we have you know supplements and
meditations online courses
um it's called soluna so then we have a
soluna juice bar inside the four seasons
so it is part of the hotel um and also
my clients can go there
so it's nice because it's enclosed and
the other one was just like a standalone
yeah now everything's closed of course
like the hotel
yeah pretty shut down for a while
probably just in time to
not have a brick and mortar point yeah
like selling things at this this day and
age of everything going on but
yeah i mean i i do rem i loved your
cleanses i was actually
it it i'd and in fact i'd be curious to
ask how you came up with it because it's
really
or like how you designed it because
it's still possible to recreate these
things at home and so
um so when i have done them like that
and recreated them
it's because of your cleanse that i'm
like i'm gonna do some smoothies in
there it doesn't all have to be
juice yes so i think you know for first
of all the reason i
got into health and wellness was because
of my own challenges
um from someone that you know is i
consider myself a recovering
perfectionist but having
eating disorders and bloating problems
and acne and all sorts of indigestion
and
lots of different things um so i've been
on the long journey i went backpacking
around the world for three years
um i've studied ayurveda i've been in
china for a long time so different
things
and one thing that i've always really
felt is such a big part
of healing digestion is fiber and we
know
fiber doesn't just fill you up and it
doesn't just
you know sweep waste out but it actually
feeds
um it feeds the bacteria in your body
and it helps to create what are called
short chain fatty acids
which increases inflammation and it just
rejuvenates your whole system
so what i found and i've done every sort
of cleanse too danica i've done water
fast i've done all juice
fast i've done a 16 day watermelon
cleanse or you just out of my yoga
studio
you just eat watermelon for 16 days i've
tried pretty much everything
and what i found in the combination of
some fiber so some smoothies
because the juice the fiber's taken out
it's just the actual
juice itself is that there's a deeper
level of healing that can happen because
you're actually
um really refortifying your gut flora
it's not you know people will do a juice
cleanse and think oh look i lost five
pounds but it's really just water weight
and then they can gain it as soon as
they start eating or it puts them on
this cycle this yo-yo
cycle whereas when you have some
smoothies in your cleanse
you are stabilizing your blood sugar
levels and you're also again
recalibrating your gut
so it's a period where you're really um
going inward and just helping to really
uh reestablish your your body's strength
so that became the most powerful
most powerful cleanse and when i started
working with clients and different
people and
men and women and all different sorts of
people i found that when i added in the
smoothies
you know that's when they started going
to a whole new level and then for the
rest of their diet besides smoothies i'm
a big
proponent of soups especially if you're
trying to
slim down or boost your energy or all
these different goals that most of us
have
soup for dinner is a really great thing
because it's the same concept as the
smoothie where it's easy to digest but
it still has
fiber and it breaks down easily and it
cleanses your system it's very
nourishing um so yeah blended
soup or would it be soup ingredients
like vegetables in it without it being
blended
so i'm actually more of a chunky soup
person
so i think you're talking about you can
but even when you're making a chunky
soup because i like to chew a little bit
the veggies have been so
cooked down and then infused with
different spices ginger and different
things that it's still easy to digest
blended soups are great too of course
okay i wanna i could spiral off on food
and wellness and we will
but you touched on kind of how you got
into wellness so
i'd love to hear about that i'd love to
hear about like how old were
you and what brought on those issues
that you fought and overcame and learned
from
like take me back in time to before
it was health and wellness guru
really you know take me back to the
younger years
yeah it's it's so funny because i just
feel like this whole time danica i've
just been sharing things i've learned
that have worked in my body and the
journey keeps going keeps expanding
but if i look back i look at a you know
a pretty insecure teenager that grew up
in connecticut
and everybody was white and i happened
to be
you know asian and hispanic and some
white so i'm mixed
and i just really just didn't feel
comfortable i didn't feel good in my
body
so i think for a lot of us women
especially you start trying to control
things that you can
um which you know is often food because
you can see it you can pick it up and so
i started really obsessing about my body
this was you know sophomore junior year
in high school um so i started to
you know i was running track i was not
because i liked running but because i
was trying to be thin
and that's when i became bulimic and
i you know to an extent anorexia that
was never diagnosed but i was just
um you know just not comfortable in my
body
and then it swing the other way then i
went to college and i was like
wow i'm living with all my friends so
then i got into partying i was drinking
a lot
i was eating late night pizza and i'm
i'm not that tall either i i think
you're five two right
i am yeah okay so i'm just a little bit
taller than you
but i gained 30 pounds and a lot of it
was
blown into my belly and so it was just
this letting go
so i was like swinging here then i was
swinging here and then
finally i came into more of a middle
ground
and the way that happened is i um it's a
long
story but i was going to be a doctor i
went into college with a science and
math scholarship but then i interned in
hospital and i didn't like it
so i didn't know exactly what i was
going to do but i had saved up some
money and i got a job in australia it's
a marketing firm
and then i ended up traveling i was
going to travel for a couple weeks
but did i live in australia yes i was
there my junior year of college and then
after i graduated
this job i interned for had an office
there so i
worked for a year and i saved my money
and i started backpacking
and that was this whole other part of my
life
what area were you backpacking well it
started i was in australia so i was
gonna just do
thailand and southeast asia and come
back but i started meeting all these
people
and i started camping and doing it
really cheaply
um so in the end i ended up being on the
road for three years
and the important part of the story i
still get goosebumps is that i wasn't in
the western world
danica for three years so i was in
africa for about seven months
i was in asia for about 18 months and
then some eastern europe and then south
america
so that period i wasn't in the media
i was taken out of the world of dieting
and numbers and you know what everybody
thinks beauty is
and i was just in this like this
expansive realm i was in
india for months i was in china for
months so it was just this
whole um re-education
i think that i was in so then i came
back to new york city
my family's from the east coast and um
oh and along the way i was learning
about digestion i was learning about
beauty i was learning to connect
everything i was learning that
your digestion has so much to do with
your mind and you know meditation and
spirituality and
it was all these things that were
blowing my mind open so anyways i come
back to new york city and i just started
a free blog and i was going back to
nutrition school and i was teaching yoga
and i was doing all these different
things
and i was really passionate and as you
can tell i'm still really passionate
about talking about this
and it just started to really grow
organically
um the second television segment i ever
did was good morning america
and then i met one of my my when i think
she was my first celebrity um uma
thurman
and and um you know the different
magazines like vogue and l were asking
me to
you know write about different things so
it just started to expand very
um organically and then i ended up
moving to
la where a lot of my clients were and
then started that first juice bar where
you and i first
interacted and you know the books have
come now i'm writing my sixth book right
now
um you know and then so now i have a
company called seluna
and the biggest one of the biggest
things danica that i've learned and the
thing that i
really teach today is my four
cornerstone lifestyle
which is food body emotional well-being
and spiritual growth
so i look back on my journey and i look
at my first two books and they were very
focused on food and food i think is the
beginning of the wellness journey for
most of us
because we can pick it up and you can
see it and you can interact with it and
it becomes this thing that you can focus
on
but it's really about working with
energy right
you look at i know if you've read any of
my books to annika but
yeah i've i've i've read some yeah oh
god
okay is take numbers out of it so
i don't weigh myself i don't count the
calories of food
i don't ask people how old they are
sometimes i forget how old i am
um i don't live in a world world of like
finiteness and numbers it's really
working with you know what the yogis
call the underlying energy matrix of
everything
so then i started working with food and
i started understanding oh we don't have
to diet
you know we're just talking about fiber
and flow we can open up energy in our
body we can work with energy in a much
different way
um and then i see you know body is how
we exercise how we take care of our skin
and then my last book really focused on
the emotional part of well-being
and all this research about bloating and
inflammation related to our thought
patterns and holding on to guilt and
shame and anger
um and then the spiritual part i define
is just you know understanding yourself
better and connecting with yourself so
meditation being in nature all these
different things
so the reason i say this danica is
because when i worked with these clients
i worked with all these different actors
and all these different people
i would live with them for four months
this is before i had kids
um so i would travel around the world
and sometimes i would do the press tours
we'd be in a different country every day
and sometimes it would be for a film and
the way i worked with them you know i
was their nutritionist on paper but i
always say that was maybe 10 to 15
of it it was again working on all these
different principles
freeing them of these limited beliefs
and these mindsets and these ideas
opening up their body um getting them to
connect to breathe
to relax which has a big effect on your
hormones has an effect on stress
hormones
your body can release weight easily more
easily
um so i really uh when i talk about
wellness now i always say you know it
can't just be about food it can't just
be about the way you work out but it's
everything all together the emotion on
the spiritual side are really important
too
that's okay it's true like all of that
is really true you can't just address
one thing and expect it to you know
reshape your world i feel like you hear
about
you know people talking about you know
once they finally relaxed and reduced
stress in their life they just magically
lost weight and so
there's so many there's different facets
to it
um so what i'm curious like
did you learn something when you were
abroad
you know traveling that you started to
make those connections
that said yourself yes so
you know when i look back on my past i
was a chronic dieter
i was obsessed you know with numbers
with all these different things that i
tell people not to pay attention to now
and you know just like i was i mean like
i think a lot of women suffer from this
this
isn't you know like i was hard on myself
much more so
like quite a bit when i was younger too
i mean like how do we
yes yes yes so i'm i agree with you it's
a normal
it's a normal thing especially i think
for women well i think when we don't
feel comfortable or good on the inside
then we focus on the outside
you know so again when we're coming into
ourselves when we haven't gotten into
our power yet
and we realize you know beauty is so
much about our inside and our magnetism
and our
energy it's not just about the surface
um we
give away our power because we focus on
the surface so anyways for me i was you
know
i mean i'm plant-based now danica but
back then i tried
atkins and and paleo
and you know counting calories and soup
diets i tried everything in my body
and so that period where i went to
australia and i was interning
you know i i was i was pretty heavy for
my frame
and i was drinking diet soda all day and
i never went to the gym because i was
tired i was partying every night
but i happened to see this flyer and it
said you know learn how to detox
at this gym you know some class that you
guys was teaching and i didn't even know
what detoxing was this is
you know um this was you know over well
over a decade ago
and so i went and i met with this woman
and she said so tell me about your
digestion
and i was like you know i don't want to
talk about that
i want to talk about how to lose weight
can you tell me the good stuff
and at the time i didn't want to talk
about it because i was super constipated
by the way
but i was like i don't want to talk
about that and she said to me she looked
me in the eye and she said
it's all related it's all the same thing
so that's when the light bulb first came
on that
oh my digestion is related to my anxiety
to my acne to
my hair not growing to my fatigue
to my inability to lose weight so that
was when i started to
be interested in becoming a nutritionist
from working with this nutritionist and
just seeing how she could
help me um look at my life in a much
more holistic way
and so then i would say india had the
next biggest
impact i was there for months i was
studying ayurveda i was studying yoga
for the first time in meditation
and learning all these ideas about
energy so one of the reasons i became
plant-based you know i love
you know the environmental reasons and
the health reasons was actually
energetic reasons you know the fact that
when something
um and i'm not all or nothing by the way
and a lot of my clients eat meat so i
don't say
don't eat meat although i do prevent
eating more plants and more vegetables
um is that when you kill when something
with a developed nervous system
is killed it starts to decompose the
energy starts to go down
so because we're living beings and we're
trying to be you know in our fullest
vitality and meditate and go
up those kinds of energetically aren't
supportive
so i learned a lot in india i learned a
lot from many different teachers along
the way
um and then i've done many trainings
formally and informally
to come up with my philosophy today
let's just let like let's go into the
food part because i think that we could
probably spend a little bit of time on
each one of these four cornerstones
um because they hold the key um
so more about food like
what what what what is the
what do you eat on a regular basis and
why and why don't you eat certain things
you know how does our body operate like
give us like
give give us a quick overview of what's
important
so okay the quick over view danica if i
could sum it up make it really simple
and going back to our our core teaching
which is energy
right so i would say how do you want to
feel in your body
i'll ask you when i have like energy you
want to feel
you want to have you want to be strong
you want to reduce inflammation and
bloating
um yeah you mostly just want energy
energy strength vitality all these
different words right
so imagine that the the truth that is
that energy is never created
nor destroyed it transmutes so what
you're putting into your body starts to
become part of the basis of your cells
it starts to infuse throughout your body
so when you look at food what is
supportive of your body goals
right so to me it's fresh food it's food
that's grown in nature
nature is our highest teacher nature
comes in a complete nutritional package
only plant foods have fiber you know we
can get caught up in all these numbers
and um
oh am i getting enough riboflavin and
you know how many milligrams of vitamin
c are in here
um so there's great dr t colin campbell
wrote this book
um you know the china study and he says
when you eat whole foods your body does
the math
for you and i really liked that because
again i'm not a numbers-based
person but to me like the fresher the
better the more colorful the more
vibrant the more alive
now it doesn't mean you have to eat an
all raw diet uh
but it does mean you want fresher you
probably don't want you know
to eat one make one meal and eat it all
week so by day seven it's been sitting
around for a long time
i would say like nature you want to eat
a wide variety of foods
fiber i found for me is the natural form
of portion control
so you don't have to obsess about
calories because fiber will help create
bulk in your system and fill you
up so on a daily basis what that looks
like is
you know i have a glowing green smoothie
i drink hot water with lemon
um i'll just go buy you know what i'm
what i've eaten today
um i'm i have i i personally don't eat
gluten
um i know if it's because of my you know
genetic
my asian side or some people don't
tolerate gluten as well and i'm one of
those people i get really
loaded but i ate a gluten-free wrap with
micro greens and sprouts think about
baby sprout
baby plants danica they're bursting with
energy and vitality and
and all these fatty acids and amino
acids
building blocks of protein so i eat
sprouts and micro greens i try to eat
them every day
i used to grow them but i don't have
time right now but i buy them
so i have a lot of those like i have
avocado in that wrap
just very alive and then um for dinner
last night i had like a big
veggie lentil ginger soup and some
sprouted brown rice
so the reason i'm into sprouting too
which is you can get sprouted
rice by the way and lentils and nuts for
a couple dollars more
it just activates it goes back to nature
if there's a seed and it sits in water
it starts to shed the inhibitor enzymes
and it says oh it's safe for me to
blossom and to become this huge oak tree
right
if you don't put water like so it's so
it's a usable
exactly like let's say yeah look at um
just think of like a like an almond for
instance it's kind of hard right
yeah if you if you were to put that
almond in water
what happens is all this stuff comes to
the surface which are basically
inhibitor enzymes and all these out
these acids that protect the almond
because until it's ready to sprout what
if a fungus comes what if something
tries to eat it right what if
it just tries to protect itself but when
you germinate it you put it in water
in nature when you put seeds in water
they start to sprout
right they start to grow roots so it
activates it says to that seed or not
hey it's safe for you to grow you can
become this giant tree
and what that means when we sprout
grains you know all the stuff you hear
about
it's so confusing isn't it danica people
are like oh no don't eat grains
there's elected all this stuff so so i
my answer to that is you know we soak
we sprout which removes a lot of those
acids it becomes more easily digestible
in the body
um i'm a big fan i'll say right now a
big
carb fan i'm not someone that doesn't
eat carbs i'm a big fan
of dan buettner i don't know if you know
who he is he's come on my podcast too
he discovered the blue zones which are
the five healthiest
longest lived communities in the world
there's one in japan and you know
italy greece california and
costa rica and guess what they're all
thin they don't have neural
you know the same rate of neurological
disorders they're super happy all these
different factors
and i said to him hey dan do they eat
carbs and grains
and he said not only do they eat them
every day they eat them
every meal you know whether it's the
form of a sweet potato a tuber or
whatever
so i think that everybody's body is
different to some of this stuff
i think that you know different foods
interact differently for different
people
some people and i always say there's a
range you know for macronutrients so
maybe some people need more fat they do
better with more carbs or they do better
with protein
so you really have to find that right
ratio for your body there isn't one
exact right way
but i'll say overall the more alive
to we choose the more plant foods we
choose which have again fiber and such a
huge range of
antioxidants and nutrients um and you're
trying to be more seasonal
trying to really vary what we have to me
that's the foundation of a really really
powerful diet and we also know that your
gut health is activated by having a wide
range of
different plant foods so you don't want
to just have the five same five things
every day
every week but you want to just go and
explore and mix and match your veggies
and i think that's really important
as is taking the right probiotics and
there's a couple key supplements that i
think are really important too
well you should talk about what seluna
has to offer because
i know from doing your cleanses
that um you offered um like a detoxy
uh like a detox kind of i don't remember
exactly
i don't know if it was magnesium or what
exactly it was but you there was that
and then there was a probiotic but i
think you might have one other
one other item in your seluna lineup so
what
what what should we take if we're gonna
take something
that's a great question danica because i
think like anything else you can find
i've gone into clients homes and opened
their cabinet and there's been like 70
different pills
and i don't think that take did you come
to my house did you open my
pantry i'm gonna i'm gonna come there
next time i'm gonna do a clean out
actually it's you you find a lot of
adaptogens that's probably what i hoard
the most of
i think that's great i think you know
adapters things that are whole
food-based and based in actual
herbs and plants i think are amazing but
there's just a lot of
you know synthetic stuff out there
there's a lot of minutiae there's a lot
of things that
it's just i think i find superfluous
what i like to focus on first because
then we can layer on top are the
supplements that work
synergistically and they work
holistically for your whole body
to go up so we have what are called sbo
probiotics
so they're the saluna sbo probiotics and
this is based on the fact that again
nature
your ancestors danica wherever they came
from my ancestors that came from you
know the philippines and different
countries
someone comes from africa wherever you
come from there's one thing that our
ancestors have in common
and that's that they didn't have running
water so they would pull the veggies out
and they would actually
um eat a little bit of dirt because they
didn't have enough water to wash
everything
and that dirt that soil has the perfect
mix of bacterium and that's how our
ancestors got their probiotics
so our probiotics look brown they look
like the dirt
and it's not just some contrived
man-made formula it's actually
based it's based on how we used to live
danica which is in such close connection
with the earth that we used to eat the
earth
every single day so it's really powerful
you don't have to refrigerate them
because they're
so hearty that they survive stomach acid
sometimes i think all these probiotics
that are so delicate
how is this even gonna get through the
stomach acid into my gut
so probiotics i would say every day
that's my you know
probably number one thing i think people
should take just because our gut flora
gets wiped out all the time
and then the the detoxi you were talking
about so imagine
and i use this water analogy you know
when i was asking you about how you
wanted to feel danica and you were
talking about being strong
and being in your body um from a water
perspective
think about a waterfall like a water
analogy right a waterfall is powerful
it's magnetic it's moving there's flow
when you see a waterfall you want to
just stare at it right now compare that
to a stagnant pond
think about a pond you know
billabong i guess you'd call it
australia where there's scum and sort of
algae growing on top
and it's just not really beautiful it's
just not moving and it just starts to
look really gross right
so think about our bodies um it's not
just about the calories that we're
eating it's not just about you know what
we're putting in
but it's how much is also coming out
because if things start to
stick in our body if they stay toxins
you know constipation
just excess waste whatever it is it
starts to accrue and it minimizes space
in our body it minimizes oxygen
it ages us faster and we just don't have
that energy because everything is
being you know cycled through it's about
98
of our blood first for instance that
goes through our colon it can pick up
waste and redistribute it around our
body
so i think it's one of the reasons that
people age faster and i don't just mean
you know oh wrinkles but all our organs
start to decrea degrade and our vitality
goes down
and you know to me that's a big factor
of aging a big
way that people age as their energy just
starts to get lower and lower
so what detoxi does it's not a it's not
a laxative
it's not habit-forming it's nascent
oxygen with asc2p
which is a really potent form of vitamin
c and clinical research has shown when
you combine those ingredients it helps
to stop
uh shortening of telomeres which is
basically the caps on the dna
it's the root root root cause of aging
so when you're taking these supplements
you're
um just strengthening the very very
internal root of your body
and at the same time you're helping to
flush weight out a waste out
so it's sort of like a traffic jam you
know i used to live in new york city and
sometimes there'd be a traffic jam
at you know union square 14th street but
it really started uptown at 80th street
right
so when you start to release more from
your colon from your gi tract
you start to open up flow across all
your organs your entire blood flow your
body your
you know your gallbladder your liver
there's an exchange that happens between
your colon your liver
every few minutes so your whole body
starts to open up
so again this is really important
because even if you start today and you
start
you know going um spending a thousand
dollars a week on organic food and
eating perfectly
and doing all this stuff but there's
still all this waste that continues to
accrue and was there before in your body
you're never gonna look your best you're
never gonna feel your best
um so i recommend taking that in the
evening it's called detoxing people take
between one and five
depends on your body i take four
personally and the probiotics you take
two in the morning
and then our final supplement is called
their digestive enzymes they're really
powerful enzymes
and you take them right before you eat
because i always say you're not what you
die you're not what you eat you are what
you digest and these enzymes help to
break down the food
into you know the carbs the protein the
fat also the fiber
it also breaks down strains of candida
so you absorb more nutrients into your
body when you eat it's just gets
maximizing it
and it's moving it through so that you
don't get bloated
oh i i know i've had this stuff before
because i've done your cleanses and i've
been like yeah absolutely i need detoxi
and i really should have finished the
bottle probably
um as i'm does it does it it's probably
still not good
it's been many years um so i'm gonna be
ordering that
but then i'm gonna ask the gross
critical question
is that how often should we be going
number two
and like how often so i mean there's
there's a really wide range of opinions
here
and different experts will say oh well
you know what's normal for one person
isn't normal for other people or
whatever
i think in an ideal world you would go
to the bathroom every day
at least once a day yeah um guys can go
more i know my husband goes like six
times a day
but you know what does that mean i mean
you'd be shocked danica how many women
in particular i worked with that go like
once a week
sometimes once every 10 days yeah like
it can get pretty gnarly
nothing can ruin my day worse than
missing
a day that's like the worst thing in the
world it is the worst thing
you you feel heavy you just feel gross
but i will say this
even if someone goes to the bathroom you
know six times a day ten times a day
it doesn't mean that all the waste is
coming
out there can still be uh parts of
you know what you're eating and also
just the cellular breakdown that stays
in your body and it starts to
um you know what's called impaction it
starts to cement
into the sides of your gi tract your
body's hot it's a hot
mammalian body temperature it's almost
100 degrees uh so things big things sit
in there
so what's great about the toxic the
oxygen just comes and it helps to get
between your
your the side walls of your colon and
the old waste and helps to get it out
so you know just because someone poos a
lot doesn't mean that they're toxin-free
if that was the case then everybody that
was this big pooper would
would be an amazing help and energy we
know that's not true
that's definitely not true okay um
so uh the next pil the next
cornerstone so the body yes
so again this is this is interesting
danica because we're as human beings
we're having an
embodied experience right we're supposed
to be in our body but you'd be amazed at
how many people say to me
i don't know when i'm hungry i don't
know what my body wants to eat
i don't know what what i need because
people are so disconnected from their
bodies
especially women that we're up in our
heads we're overthinking we're analyzing
um we're seeing what everybody else is
doing on social media
right we're just we're just out here
we're just looking at the time of day
you're looking at the time of day and
going well it's uh eight a.m or not i
should have breakfast and now i should
have lunch
and yeah you know i i'm pretty bad about
that i feel like i'm almost always
hungry and i force myself to wait three
to four hours between each time i eat
but
you know what though because you're such
a high energy person
and i'd have to like you know look like
look at you in person a little bit or
ask you some more questions but i just
think you have a lot of um
you have a lot of vata energy ayurveda i
would say you just have a lot you
you're active you're you're healthy so
um as long as the foods are digesting
well you you know you may just have a
different eating pattern than other
people
um and you want to make sure you're
getting enough fiber so you do stay full
longer at each of your meals you're not
just eating something that's like going
through you really fast
i will say one of the weird things that
i've noticed about myself is that
i really do better with cooked food
yes yes i mean so then if anybody else
relates to me when they're listening to
this but like
roasted vegetables like cooked like
potatoes and cauliflower
and all that stuff like that works so
much better than
like for me raw food cold actually
smoothies gives me a stomachache
yes well first of all it's a lot of
fiber and when we cook
when we cook veggies we break them down
we make the fiber it's much easier to
digest
cooked foods so i'm a proponent of both
i think we definitely want to have a lot
of cooked foods in our diet
but the problem with cooking is that it
does denature vitamin c
and enzymes um so you if you are going
to eat mostly cooked which is you know
fine and ayurveda would really like that
actually just make sure you're taking
your digestive enzymes
so that you're not taking all of your
own body's enzymes to break down the
food
and i still think some raw food like
fresh fruit with all the vitamins
or you could try taking the enzymes
before a smoothie
also some people get bloated from
smoothies because they chug them
since they're whole foods you really
want to chew them well
and mix your saliva to break them down
enough
so that could be a reason that people
don't do well also improper combining
you don't want to put a bunch of protein
powder with like a bunch of
um you know fruit for instance and the
fruit breaks down really fast and
protein takes longer
so if we simplify our smoothies like i
make protein smoothies
with protein powder and banana which is
a you know a slower digesting fruit that
doesn't have water
you can't juice a banana but you can
make smoothies out of it so
um anyway that's a whole other
discussion but my first book the beauty
detox solution talks about food
combining
and that is you know when you start to
learn some of the principles of that
that can really help
bloating and issues with raw food too
thank you i've actually always been
curious about that
and i've wondered if it has something to
do with sort of because you had
mentioned
vada and so what are the what are the
three
um what would they be called in
ayurvedic doshas like the different body
types
so we all have you know different levels
of
of you know most people aren't just one
they're you know they may be dominant in
two
very rare someone is try doshik but vata
is the wind
energy and usually people that have vata
are you know they can be smaller and
thinner
kapha is is earth so it's
like you know steady slower moving a
little bit heavy
easy to gain weight body type and then
pitta is fire
so really great digestion um
really moody gets really hangry if they
don't eat right away like needs that
fuel
um fiery nature so um so you
so probably because you're this you know
race car
driver you have all the adrenaline i say
you're probably pitovata
so uh probably a good person and then
you know that
makes you know that makes sense so you
you you know the
everybody's body is different but the
cooked foods for you would probably do
really well and like i said i would take
i would still do digestive enzymes i
would still do
some because the fire can get out of
control you want to make sure your
nervous system is soothed all the time
so things like tulsi tea you can just
sip on when you're working when you're
around it's really great for your
system so it's an herbal it's an indian
herb
uh basically it's called holy um indian
holy basil
so you can just sip on it that would be
really good for your nervous system
so speaking of body danica like think
about your nervous system yoga and aruba
talks a lot about our nervous system we
don't talk about it as much in the west
but our nervous system well we're
starting to with like fight-or-flight
mode right people talk about your
sympathetic system versus your
parasympathetic but this has always been
such a huge
focus of ayurveda and yoga is not
aggravating your nervous system
when you aggravate your nervous system
you affect your endocrine system
and your immunity and obviously
everybody right now is trying to keep up
their immunity
so your nervous system is like if we're
always just
really reactive to everything going
around us and we're you know our anxiety
levels and our stress is high
we actually weaken our bodies we make
ourselves very susceptible
so when we're talking about the body
cornerstone from a wellness perspective
one of the best things you can do is to
give yourself a little veda says it's
the number one
um anti-aging rejuvenative practice
which is called recyana
is very simple short two minute uh
self self-massage so you're supposed to
do it with warm oil like coconut oil
and then you're supposed to take a
shower and it seems really simple but
touch is one of the best ways to soothe
your nervous system that's why massages
are so
feels so good but you can do it to
yourself day in and day out
and just to soothe your body also
remember your skin is your largest organ
so body is you know not maybe not doing
hot yoga in the middle
of august when it's already really hot
outside if that doesn't feel
good to you it's really adjusting the
way that you exercise
to be aligned with what feels good to
you in that moment so it's how we
exercise it's how we take care of our
skin
i also have a high performance non-toxic
natural skincare line
because probably because i had so many
skin problems and i had really bad acne
and
patchiness and rosacea all this stuff so
i really do enjoy skincare too
so all of that is in the body so
beautiful
skin's really beautiful thank you see
how hard it is for women to take
to to accept compliments i'm like
whatever even though i love to
compliment people so i'll take that and
i'll say thank you
see i'm still uh yes and you know
i mean like that opens up a door to
something that i've
like been contemplating a lot and so we
can keep going down these like concepts
and about things you know but let's riff
on this idea and so
because this kind of plays into i think
perhaps
maybe the you know emotional part of you
where
i agree with you it's hard to it can be
hard to accept a compliment
and it would be because i
it because in my mind as i've been
unpacking is like
if we don't believe it about ourselves
we can't we
it's harder to accept it from someone
else because we're like
we blow it off about ourselves and so
you know
i've been working on that working on
sort of more confidence and
more ownership in this like very
kind way and in fact somebody suggested
it to me that
you know imagine that it's like the
little girl in me that's being
compliment
complimented as opposed to being so
direct at me so that i
so that it can be accepted but i believe
i i believe that that's that's part of
that sort of
self love that you have for yourself
that then you can accept the compliments
does that
resonate with you oh 100 um i think that
it's easy for us to deflect
right we have to really um know it and
feel it
and one of the biggest things that i've
been working on danica in that regard
is um not feeling you know i'm beautiful
or i'm um enough because of all the
things i
do but just because of me being me you
know right like just
that's the essence of yoga we'll say you
know you are important you
are amazing because you're living and
breathing and that's it
so it's easy to get caught up in
achievements and i'm like oh look at my
book did really well
or look my hair looks good today but
what about the days when my hair doesn't
look good and what about the times where
maybe i don't make that list or i don't
do that does that mean i'm not good
enough anymore
it's you know this external point of
reference when we're like relying on
validation and compliments and likes on
social media to feel good enough
it means we never do because it keeps
moving and it keeps shifting
so for me the big work is you know
skipping to the fourth corner stone is
spiritual practice which i define is
just you know
whatever you do to understand yourself
better and connect with yourself
and so that's sitting in stillness uh
for me meditation being in nature
because i could say to you you know
danica oh my god it's so
amazing look at all your you know things
you've accomplished it's amazing
and it is amazing by the way but you
know for women and you know
being a pioneer and you're doing all
this amazing stuff with you know race
car driving and
all this stuff but still with all your
achievements
when i look at you you're this unique
soul there's no one like you you're this
beautiful person so i say i
see you not your achievements and it's
it's you being worthy and amazing isn't
dependent on that you don't have to keep
getting more
achievements you don't have to keep
winning more races to be enough
and that's i think the problem with our
society is you know these dopamine hits
and we put something up and people
you know a million people like it so
we're like oh look people like me for
this
or you know winning whatever it is so we
start to think we start to chase that
and it becomes exhausting and then when
we don't get it then we start to feel
like aren't i good enough aren't i
worthy anymore
you know it's like the mom like her
whole self-worth maybe in just raising
her kids
so when her kids grow up she's like what
do i do or if an actress right
there or she doesn't get roles she's
like well i guess no one cares about me
but that's the falseness that's you know
that's a limited belief that we create
it's not that's not why you're beautiful
that's not why you're worthy has nothing
to do with out here it has to do with
the fact that you
are a unique soul there's no one like
you
and so no one can take that away from
you
mm-hmm it's such a journey it never ends
either
it never ends but there there comes a
day where you know for me
and i'm writing about this in my new
book where you you change from what's
called an external point of reference
where your whole idea about yourself is
created from the outside
look everybody's looking at me everybody
likes me or they don't like me
or people really liked you know for me
that book or they like that project or
they like that it's all from the outside
and that's your reference for something
does good or not
and then when you start doing this four
quarters styled lifestyle and you start
to really
think about your feelings and you
journal and you meditate what happens is
you switch to what's called an internal
point of reference
where it means you know when you do your
best
you know you're showing up you know
you're just being yourself you're being
authentic
you're being sincere and that means
maybe that isn't the biggest post or
maybe this didn't do that well
but it doesn't take away your confidence
because you're connected to yourself on
the inside
and that's your real source of safety
and security
it's like how do i get here because it's
hard to know it is hard to know it's
hard to know who am i
exactly and what does make me happy and
exactly you know that's such a journey
for all of us and it also evolves right
so it's kind of an evolutionary
process that's right it changes because
we shift
but i will say so the first two
cornerstones are food and body and those
are
you know very physical and quite um you
know you can see them you can pick them
up you can touch them so those are like
you know easier starting points so the
next point is so for the body though
because i want to make sure i want to
make sure we give somebody
you know give give them a tangible like
we talked a lot about food but in body
is it about
physical activity or is it just about
the nervous system
no so anything that has to you know
anything related to your body that's not
food so skin care using less toxic
products
modifying your exercise routine um based
on the season or based how you feel
supplements would fall into bodies like
we talked about um so i would say you
know just really
listen to your body i used to have this
like hardcore
hour and a half yoga practice and then
when my mom passed away a couple years
ago
i didn't want to do it anymore i wanted
to ground myself so i started doing
beach walks and now i do more hikes and
you know it's just like not forcing but
going in
um really listening to what your body
needs um
so yeah skin care supplements i would
say you know touching that self massage
is really healing
um so anything related to body is
in that second cornerstone really focus
on that okay
yeah emotional well-being is uh
emotional well-being and spiritual
spiritual um your spiritual growth are
really interesting
because they're the ones that i think
people ignore and what happens is if you
ignore
some of the cornerstones you obsess over
the other one one or two
so for me i wasn't in touch with my
emotions and my feelings so i became
obsessed with my body and food i
had eating disorders the emotional side
is where we start to understand our
feelings
and we let ourselves feel our feelings
so they come out
so for instance have you ever noticed it
so for me
i'll say it um i used to get really
annoyed when
anybody i felt like people didn't listen
to me so like let's say you interrupt me
let's say it just seems like you know
you're you're just listening your
opinion not listening to mine whatever
it was it was this huge trigger would
make me really upset and i would kind of
avoid somebody or whatever it was
when i started um focusing on this
cornerstone i started journaling a lot
and you can start to see different
patterns and you can start to process
things and i started to let myself feel
and realize oh you know this
something like you know we all have
stuff from our childhood it came from
feeling not seen and not heard and then
it became this whole thing i constructed
my life around like
achieving really high so people would
have to see me and getting really
annoyed
but the problem is we stick in those
patterns unless we start to see them
so the practice with emotional
well-being is journaling i think is the
easiest thing
i journal just a couple minutes a day
it's a safe space to be authentic and to
see
your feelings and to see and you can
start to sit back and separate from your
feelings
um so i teach a lot about journaling
because i think even with your best
friends or your mom or your husband or
your wife
you don't want to share everything right
but we know that
emotional well-being and mental health
is related to bloating it is related to
inflammation it is related to aging so
even though you don't see it
if you just sit there all day and anger
um and things become unresolved it
really starts to break down your body
so it's very interesting i i wonder if
you
get this too but for me um
i in my emotional well-being shows up in
my body in a very direct way
but the problem is is it shows up in my
body before is
where i'm aware of it in my mind so
when something's coming through to
process something big something
emotional
um usually it's my solar plexus
yeah and it's usually in my stomach
right there for those who don't know the
solar plexus it's the fourth chakra it's
right sort of at the top of your stomach
it's like that where you get the nervous
energy
um and it will like i i will like
digestion goes down
um sometimes i've even felt ill like
sick i can't eat a thing
and um but generally like digestion and
bloating are a big thing like i just
can't
can't can't get away from this knotted
feeling in my stomach and nothing is
going on
in my mind as far as what's go what's my
world
but i know now because it's happened so
many times and i'm
aware and i'm present and i'm paying
attention to how i feel
and i also have a good diet to know like
oh it wasn't because i had pizza i
don't have pizza so like it was it's i'm
pretty consistent with my diet and so
yeah i wonder if you if that sort of
thing resonates with you
if you feel like that happens in your
body exactly so what in that case danica
it would be
noting when that happens and then
you're thinking to yourself you know
what was the precursor to this
last night did i have a stressful
conversation with somebody
did something get triggered did i um you
know some
painful subject get brought up or you
know whatever it was try to backtrack a
little bit and see
and every time this happens you can
start to create those patterns like for
me i had no clue that i had this thing
about not being seen
which then i equated with not being
loved or lovable but when i started to
see it and it came
like black and white it just came
because i was you know tracking this
with my journal
awareness is a huge part of emotional
well-being then it doesn't mean we're
perfect it doesn't mean it still doesn't
bother us but we start to create that
distance that comes with awareness and
then we can work on it and then we can
create
new ideas new beliefs and we can
overcome it
there's this really amazing psychologist
called dr david hawkins and he's his
book called letting go
and he talks about the difference
between feelings and thoughts
and imagine that thought that may have
led up to this danica or someone
you know someone having a stomach not
maybe like you know that person's a big
a-hole
they're so mean you know whatever it is
like they suck and it just keeps going
around and around in your head it's a
thought
but if you drop into your body and you
start to feel
okay this is a tightening in my solar
plexus or like i start to have this
weird feeling in my heart and you tune
into that feeling
he says it lasts about no more than 10
minutes so it's this intensity
but then it passes through you and you
let go of that emotion
you let yourself feel it and then you
let it go if we don't let it go
it ends up getting suppressed and
repressed into our body and into our
cells and then it starts to lead to
bloating and indigestion
and um you know all sorts of aches and
pains and joint issues and all sorts of
things
so what i would contemplate danica is
you know is there something that you
don't want to feel
um you or anyone you know not just you
but you know for me
it's something you don't want to look at
is it a pattern is it a way you react
and you know what is
being held in your body and then you can
start to unpack it for yourself and no
one else can do this work for you
because obviously you're the only one
feeling it
but it's really really powerful and if
you're you know if you're banging your
head you're like i'm eating perfectly
and i'm doing all this stuff and i gave
up dairy and i'm still bloated and i
still can't lose 10 pounds
for a lot of people i've worked on
worked with this emotional part
is huge and when you start to help
yourself process that it's amazing how
many
um i had one man lose 80 pounds once
when we started
really getting into this stuff
yeah wow that's incredible do you think
that you cuz okay so i heard you say
if you go into the feeling you feel it
lasts no more than 10 minutes
do you can you get out of
this um
trapped emotion or this held emotion or
this awareness
that your body is letting you letting
you know about
without going through an actual
emotional
process meaning do you
can you just witness it and let it go
away or do you
actually have to be vulnerable enough
with yourself
to cry essentially and
really feel or scream some people might
need to like
scream into a pillow or go run down the
road and back
or for me it's no it's usually cry but
can you process it by witnessing it
versus just
versus actually going through the
emotions because i really do have a
uh for me i totally believe in growing
pains as in like it will be painful to
go through emotional growth but
it's kind of required that's right you
agree
i do agree i think sometimes the only
way out is through it
but again i think that we can get solace
from the idea
that from knowing it's only going to be
about 10 minutes or so
according to hawkins it's not like we
stay in this intensity for
a long long time and we have to wallow
it wallow in it the problem is most
people danica don't want to feel
anything so it's so easy to distract you
can
you drink alcohol you can go on youtube
or instagram
or you know watch netflix or whatever
and so it keeps getting buried down
buried down and again people are just
like
it's got to be the diet maybe i'm not
getting enough of this or that like
there's this obsession with one
cornerstone
when really it's looking at this part of
you know of our lives the parts that
people can't see the emotional and
mental part
um i find if i get disappointed or i'm
scared of something all the
emotions i don't want to feel but i let
them myself feel them
it does get better it does come through
and they say it's like a well
so let's say anger is your big thing and
you let yourself feel the anger
really feel it instead of holding on to
resentment it keeps going down
the more times you do this and
eventually you get to the bottom of the
well
where the same thing doesn't make you as
angry anymore
and i can say that from personal
experience that has been the truth
for me and um and then you feel a lot
lighter
and then you know you're not as
sensitive you can go through life just
feeling like you're not as triggered and
that's huge
huge so like you know
i get so excited i never really like i
was doing this with my clients danica
you know doing this processing but then
i didn't really define these
cornerstones until after um you know i
had this big huge life change where
you know my mom passed away and going
through this huge breakup everything
kind of happened at the same time and i
just started
looking at everything and by the way
this technique of feeling
is how i was able to get through that
grief you know grief can hang on for
20 years for some people but feeling it
like you said it's not
fun it doesn't feel good but you go
through it
and then it starts to come out of your
body and then you can start to move
forward little by little
i really was not buying into the 10
minute thing
too much but now that you've mentioned
it the
pinnacle of it the alchemization
is maybe 10 minutes but there's a lead
up
and there's um
there's a surrendering that has to
happen
to that point and so that can take a
while well hold on
just remember though when i say 10
minutes i mean only
feeling if you start thinking and you're
like this sucks this isn't fair
i'm better i should have won whatever it
is that can last
for years so when you do this process
you
literally have to say to your brain i'm
not listening to any thoughts and you
have to drop
into your body and feel the feelings
inside your body
which is where a lot of trauma and a lot
of repression is held
tell me more about a couple years ago
like what
you know what happened what were
epiphanies like so there had to where
there were some moments that
you had aha moments
a couple years ago when you said
everything was kind of yeah yeah
it was a really like it was crazy
because my mom is you know was always so
healthy
and you know she by the time when we
found out we she had cancer she was gone
in six weeks
and so it was just like oh my god every
anything and everything can happen in
this life
and so i ended up um you know
just looking at my whole life and
reevaluating everything and i ended up
you know moving out on my own i went
through this big breakup
with my partner at the time who is the
um
husband he's the father of my first son
so i became a single mom
and it was something like i never
thought was gonna happen to me
you know again half of my family's from
the philippines where divorce is still
illegal
so this is like a big yeah it's just
like this
whole big thing that happened and um
i sort of was the breakup something was
the breakup part of you
kind of admitting certain things to
yourself
facing certain things or was this
something that was inflicted onto you
that you had to then deal with
no no i think that when my mom passed i
looked at everything in my
life and just became like it's like i
woke up and i was like you know this guy
is great like he's an amazing guy
but um you know we just weren't right
for each other and i i
really you know want a deep spiritual
connection with my partner which is what
i have now
um so i just feel like i hit rock bottom
danica i would go
and like cry in the closet i look at
everything and one of the
and then i just started to rebirth and
one of the things that came out of that
is seluna so when you think about what
is saloon it means the sun and the moon
so it means like the light and the dark
so i started looking at everything
differently like don't run away from
hard feelings
don't think it's just about the food
it's this idea of everything's all
together in the pot and we are whole and
everything's in our
part of us too so you know the dark is
where seeds start to germinate and grow
um and shamans talk about the dark being
necessary for transformation you go into
the dark
you go into those hard feelings and then
you grow um so for me i came out on the
other side i started selena i started
talking about these cornerstones
um i started talking a lot about this
the spiritual part of
you know my philosophy which is
something that's been so huge for me and
i was doing with my clients but
i was talking about food more publicly
so i just
you know this whole part of you know
what we were talking about earlier about
internal reference
uh started to come alive for me and
feeling you know
truly confident for being myself not
just all these
endless achievements i was trying to do
so uh so yeah big shifts happened a few
years ago
which is where this whole philosophy has
has
um come from so it was a breakdown
breakthrough
breakdown rock bottom breakthrough
and then now i'll say the happy ending
is that you know i
so when this happened my um this monk
that i meet with from time to time from
the self-realization fellowship
yoga center he said treat your home like
an ashram for five months
you know just do your practice read your
spiritual text like don't go out too
much don't do anything
so i did that i just kind of reset and i
focused on these cornerstones i focused
on myself
and then you know when i was ready i
started going out again and doing things
and then one night
um i went to this random actually it was
a podcaster dinner
but some of these people that have been
on my podcast so i barely knew i got
invited to this random dinner party
and i went in and boom i met john my
husband
and he says within 15 minutes he knew he
knew i was going to be his wife
but we ended up we went on three dates
in 24 hours we went on a beach walk and
then he came with me to this
work event i had to do and then um yeah
you know we got married and then uh
you know pretty had a baby and pretty
yeah and then the first time we tried to
have a baby we had a baby so now we have
our second son together
and um it just you know i i would just
say to anyone who's like oh god like i
know my life isn't exactly right or this
doesn't feel right i would say you know
you can make it right like you can you
can not everything's going to be perfect
but if you stay authentic to yourself
if you really start to connect with
yourself you connect with what you
deserve
you connect with you know this whole um
concept that we are whole
we are worthy because just because we're
breathing just because
you're danica and i'm kimberly and
there's no one else like us and when you
come from that deeper place you start
attracting different relationships and
different opportunities
and you just feel it feels really good
to be authentic
mm-hmm well that kind of leads to the
spiritual element
which is i i'm
it's near and dear to me i mean waking
up and meditating and yoga
and even just kind of beyond that into
the
realm of sort of the metaphysical realm
um
into yeah i mean i could ramble on about
all that but what is the spiritual
practice for you
so think about how much time we spend
you know talking to your best friend or
making a meal
or playing with your kid or you know all
these we spend time with a lot of
different things
but for me i define the spiritual path
as you know connecting with and
understanding yourself
you know what's inside of you who are
you really and you need
time to do that you need time where it's
not just doing doing again this external
stuff but going inside
so when you sit in meditation when you
sit in stillness when you sit in nature
you have that opportunity to listen to
yourself more to connect
and i do have a um a defined spiritual
practice not just sitting in emptiness
and doing nothing
but really you know learning to work
with your breath and the life force and
techniques i practice kriya yoga um
so for me it's just what's korea yoga so
it's a it's a it's an ancient form of
yoga
um that was taught by paramahansa
yogananda this yogi
amazing yogi who actually brought yoga
to america so
um for me it's just doing a practice it
can start with five minutes but just
really the consistency of sitting with
yourself instead of being on your phone
or watching or talking
again this is how you start to get your
power you start to go from
external to internal and then it changes
everything
and guess what the more connected you
are to yourself very practical everyday
things like food cravings start to go
away
mindless eating um you just all
weight can come off you know all these
things are trying to find your soulmate
everything starts to come
in when we become more connected to our
inner world
so it's not what society teaches as you
know it's all
you know buy stuff look here do more of
this
but interestingly enough for thousands
of years the yogis have taught that to
go inside to access your power and
that's
that's really where it is so that's i
get it
i agree but that's still not clear
enough i feel like especially if this is
not common lingo to say so let me
let me say really really um simply let's
say in the morning
this can be the beginning of your
spiritual path so again spiritual
doesn't mean religious
it's not dogmatic it's not anything like
that it's just think about it as
connection
so in the morning when you wake up and
you can do this you can just sit up in
your bed
let's say before you go into your email
before you go into instagram before
you're pulled into the outside world
just literally sit up in your bed
straighten your spine
close your eyes and even if it's three
minutes i call this with my clients so
i'm trying to get them
to give me they're like i don't have
time for anything give me three minutes
just listen to your breath literally
just
your breath and do that and i promise
you if you do that consistently that's
the beginning of your practice
you're more centered you're in your body
you can feel what you need to eat more
you can feel when you're hungry
you start to be less thrown off from
other people because you're in your own
breath your breath will be probably
slower and fuller for hopefully at least
the rest of the morning
so that's the beginning just a few
minutes here and there
of connecting in and you can do that
before you fall asleep
don't fall asleep to tv don't fall
asleep to other people's ideas but just
connect back in with your body and
create a little bit of stillness
and out of that stillness intuition
builds and
you know all sorts of things start to
come forth don't worry about all that
just start to have a few minutes a day
where you sit with yourself
and that is very very powerful
so you know next
50 phases on as i'm sure where you're at
but explain what that means when you get
into intuition
like how does that arrive for you what
do you hear
do you see things do you just know
things
so explain how intuition comes up for
you
thank you love i love talking about this
i think that we all we
all have intuition right we all have
this incredible
sixth sense inside of us the problem is
again if it's so
noisy if we're so used to just asking
everybody else what they think
and we're getting all the opinions you
don't listen to that intuition
so for me again the more i sit in
meditation um
i just you know i just like to be in
nature i go for a walk outside the more
still i become
the more for me intuition comes in which
feels like a
thought that just drops in but i call it
a download
and i get more and more downloads the
more i do this which isn't doesn't come
from logical thinking it doesn't come
from my mind it's coming from somewhere
else
and i could feel it so it just feels
like something drops in
or i tend to get a feeling um about
someone like is this the right person
for me to work with or
you know the right relationship for this
or that and it's just a feeling you have
that
we can all develop more just from
spending more time with ourselves
like assureness yes knowing this i'm
sure
a knowing assureness of just about what
you need to do
and there's no more justification beyond
just that's what you believe
that's right it's the next step to take
it doesn't mean you don't you may not
know the whole path
but it's direction on one step at a time
and that you can know and so it keeps
you it gives you direction and energy
and strength to keep moving forward
you know whether it's could be as simple
as you know the intuition of you know my
body really needs an apple right now
not an orange or not a pile of you know
cashews
it could just be like really intuiting
your body and then it starts to
um expand into bigger and bigger things
mm-hmm
yeah i love those um memes or gifts or
more like memes when they talk about
intuitive eating they're like
the tube of eating is i had told me i
had to eat a pizza you know intuitive
eating told me
but you know what i i think sometimes
if you need that sort of stress release
and it's like it's gonna give you
something and you're going through
something you know the psychology of
food cravings is something i wrote about
in my third book
you know crunching down on something
like a chip is just a way to release
tension eating a bunch of ice cream
which is soft and soothing sugary is
like giving yourself a hug
so i would say if that's really what you
feel like you need to do
do it and don't feel guilty be aware
you know hopefully don't make it a huge
pattern but sometimes you need that you
know our goal is never 100
our goal is never perfection it's 80 you
know that's the goal sometimes we don't
hit 80
but still that 20 is a lot of leeway to
play with and to be human
well what do you you obviously have such
an awareness to yourself
you have you know have so many
you know quality practices that help you
develop things but like
what do you do what do you do to help
you grow
more what what what do you do
i guess it would be externally but are
there any things that you do to continue
to feed you to help you
help provoke growth sure so i'm a huge
reader
first of all um you know i'm pretty
pretty nerdy i don't own a tv but i just
think i've always been drawn to the
written word
so i don't listen to ebook i really do
like books i really do like the written
word
and i do like modern books but i still
always go back
to um spiritual scripture so this is the
bhagavad gita
this thing is still on my desk like i'm
always flipping through
i really love you know wisdom and poetry
and and
again scripture so i try to read again
every day it doesn't happen every day
but i try to infuse
myself with that with you know whatever
form of wisdom i can
every day and there's some modern um uh
you know authors i love a lot i love
eckhart tolle i love deepak chopra
who i actually co-authored my fourth
book with so
i think you know reading for me is a
really huge form of nourishment
um i'm also really big into women's
circles so
before quarantine i you know we have
something called the selena circle which
is live i do them in different cities we
also have an online circle
where we talk about a theme this month
our theme is
honing your focus last month it was
overcoming self-doubt so i really love
um sitting in a circle with other women
especially where we can be vulnerable
and share
and learn from each other uh so that's
something that was a big practice for me
too
is vulnerability something that comes
naturally to you
no oh god no it doesn't come naturally
to anybody i mean i think you have to
learn how to be vulnerable right
i think especially to i think you know
first
generation immigrant um there's a
toughness that comes i think when an
immigrant
like my mom was really tough and she
came on a
you know academic scholarship and it was
like you know we're
working like trying to get ahead and get
out of poverty and make it
so um you know there's a love but
there's a little bit of hardness that
comes with that too so sometimes you
know vulnerability wasn't practiced in
my family
for sure so it's something i've had to
learn along the way
um and something i've really worked on
um with my husband
and deepening our relationship and you
know sometimes i get annoyed but then
now trying to work on saying you know
actually makes me hurts my feelings and
that's why i don't like it when you do
that
you know because i can cover anger i can
cover anger over my vulnerability but
i'm learning to let my
you know the soft underbelly show and
when i'm really hurt
[Music]
that's critical for connection it is it
is and it's really deepened our
our marriage and you know all my
relationships so the circle for me was
that practice of being vulnerable
with friends with other women which i
think you know was hard for me too
because i wanted to show certain sides
and maybe hide other sides but
um but yeah you know we keep learning
and going and
practicing all these things and then you
can look back in the year and i look
back and
you know when i tell you that epiphany
from a couple of years ago and i think
wow like i really have
you know i've grown and so for that i
give myself a pat on the back i think
sometimes we have to acknowledge what
we've done and not just keep getting to
the next level
i agree i agree we can have destination
syndrome and we can be very judgmental
and you know to be able to stop for a
second and just be like
yeah that's pretty good actually and
we're proud of ourselves
yeah well well well done on helping so
many people
um with how to live
their best life like how to be happy and
how to
get into your body so that you can um
you know stop seeking so much externally
and find it internally thank you for
helping so many people do that
thank you thank you and and for giving
birth to the ggs drink
you have all the things i've given birth
to my books these recipes that gigi
asked my children it's
it's funny it seems like i have a lot of
babies now danica
well for those who don't know the ggs is
the glowing green smoothie
and that would be like the cornerstone
of your cleanse yeah it's
um the corn you know one of the
cornerstones within the food cornerstone
right exactly greens um blending easily
digestible
for sure yeah give us the recipe for
that and we'll end on that as like a
parting note for people to
go ahead and go make in their kitchen
great so i would just say think about it
in terms of ratios
so it's going to be about 70 greens and
you can mix and match your greens but
you know
kale spinach dark leafy romaine
um if you're okay with herbs cilantro
parsley are really great to cleanse your
system as well
so when you're looking at your blender
you're gonna put depending on how much
you make one or two cups of water
no almond milk no coconut water this is
just keep it simple
water 70 greens and then you're going to
blend those two things together because
the greens need more work
to break down and then you're going to
add lemon and
about 30 percent high fiber fruit which
is usually for me
apples pears banana now
the reason that's use the lemon do you
squeeze the lemon or do you just cut the
rind off
a lot i cut the rind because i want more
of that fiber
the lemon is really important because it
rebuilds our liver which is our main
detoxifying organ our main
fat burning organ it helps to really
give your smoothie a high threshold of
vitamin c
which helps your body absorb the
non-heme iron the plant-based iron
and then the fruit is you know besides
adding natural sweetness it's putting
all those vitamins in your body and then
the greens are all the minerals
and antioxidants so it's a very complete
beautiful
smoothie so again about one to two cups
of water
70 of however much you're making green
30
high fiber fruit and you know again
depending half or one whole lemon
and that's it blend it up
well thank you so much and um this has
been really fun talking to you
uh yeah so inspirational
and so beautiful thank you so much
danika it's so
great i admire what you've done in the
world
groundbreaker for women so it's a real
honor and i really love talking to you
thank you thanks everybody for listening
to the pretty intense podcast today i
hope you enjoyed it
if you like what you heard today and you
want to hear more please click on the
subscribe button